today we had a chance to sit down with
the cast from the new MacGyver you know
they are rebooting the 80 series and we
talked to the young man who is filling
those secret agent shoes Luca still is
playing the ingenious blonde and helping
out
CSI alum George EADS first day on set
when I showed up I was looking for Lucas
and what he was shooting it was him
climbing in a jet from blowing these big
jet fans on him and I said okay this is
what we're doing we're starting yeah got
the jacket and the Swiss Army knife you
know I guess I'm a diver right Chili's
best known for playing havoc in the
x-men films he's 25 years old and in
contrast Richard Dean Anderson was 35
when we first met MacGyver back in 1985
this is a role that affords the
opportunity to do very physical things
like I do sky dive and scuba dive the
ironic thing about it is that they won't
let me do my stunt double has been I was
surprised when I was telling him as he
was jumping out of a helicopter
yesterday right before I roll like a
loose man be careful if you get hurt and
if we each he was on the set many times
over its seventh season I'll be right
back after this word and now till is set
to reclaim that MacGyver magic for a new
generation he can make his cell phone
out of a Snickers bar to make
I'll show you later well the original
MacGyver was produced by Henry Winkler
and he's producing this one too